Seeing life from the heavens,...
...looking down, helps us be more aware of the incredible nature of our world.
That's what our brand is all about:...
...helping you capture and relive experiences that celebrate you as a human.
And that's why we built Karma.
It's not just aerial, it's not just handheld, it's not just wearable or mountable,...
...Karma is all of these things.
It's a complete system.
There's a lot of very complicated technology that goes into making Karma.
Our challenge was really to take something that is conventionally very complex...
...and simplify it enough that anyone can go take Karma...
...and put it up in the air with no problem whatsoever.
From the get-go, we set out to design Karma to be incredibly portable.
We didn't want you to have to ask yourself, "Do I want to take Karma today?"
We wanted to make it so convenient that you would ask yourself,...
..."Why wouldn't I take the Karma today?"
It's all in that one case.
It's ready to go, backpack style.
What's great about Karma is that if I bring it and don't use it,...
...it still doesn't get in the way of my experience at all.